morning everybody we'll get we'll get
started and good morning to anybody
who's watching us on youtube hope you
have a nice experience
uh welcome to ons internal
on this uh this fine date
we'll get started straight away
apologies for absent how and we've got
sandra sandra yeah
thank you chair apologies from council
about
[Music]
right
is it is somebody subbing to
richard then no
no
there isn't a sub no not today okay all
right okay
okay
item two minutes pages three six
i'll go through pages phase three
all those in favor
yeah
okay
actually
79.
does anybody feel that minute 69 should
be dropped from this because
i've got no idea when it will ever
get sorted
anybody
shall we
shall we take it off or leave it on
off
anybody
i don't think it's a realistic action
point anymore probably just a feel good
comment but you know but the reality is
that maybe it's it's not really
so we'll take it off yeah yeah although
in favor yeah okay
sandra that will come off yeah
uh 59
okay
a
contribution so advice when works to the
lifting i think that is um completed
to what i know which is completed
okay
money to provide costs of the fish stock
uh which you've done and completed so
that's that
okay
move on
public contributions
uh declarations of interest
you all know uh the situation with
declarations of interest no need for me
to go through all that
edge of match has brought forward with
the permission of the chair i haven't
got any urgent matches
okay
right
agreements with uh of agenda
items part one and two well we've got no
part
item number eight
uh pages
1934 the qbl one
okay and i think we've got
you're
this is turned on now
uh qbl once performance at the end of
june 21
just to start with
um
we have a new qbr format
and tuscan finish group i looked at the
qpr and decided the uh
when an audit trail from the strat plan
through to the delivery of his actions
wanted to make the qbr more accessible
easy to read in order to kind of remove
distractions so that she just focused on
the current year performance
so we've now got the qpr one done in the
new formats
uh we've got enhanced reporting which
davidson turkeys do
we've managed to get these 3g plan
actions in there reporting against
fergus against them
and our performance indicators we've got
the comments alongside the indicators
so don't keep that one we'll do qr2
in the september meeting you can have a
look at the qbr formats
um so you want to make any improvements
that's going to say basically it's a
very dynamic document now it's in word
so we can change it up quite easily your
qbi was very static couldn't really
amend the format but now
because we've changed it if the
committee wants to change things that
things take things out it's gonna be
easy to do in the future so
i'll leave looking in september it can
be an ongoing review process
so theme one
just some highlights here
obviously northern borough center is now
officially opened
there's a community renewal fund in
place to help kickstart the local
economy uh david's team managed to pay
99.7 percent of invoices within terms
which is great
and you'll notice in the
finances the planning and plan charge
income is still higher than budget so
we're still seeing very high volumes
coming in on a downside there there are
still very high numbers claiming
universal credit in the district
and i've included this a few kind of
benchmarking charts in here so when we
do benchmarking we look at our
nearest neighbors so that's the 15
councils who are the most similar to
television in terms of economic and
social
i've also added in their north devon as
a local comparative and something like a
national one so the first one i picked
here is just um
potentially people in the economy
claiming out of her benefits
so turj is the blue strip
north devon's are green
and the national one is the black one so
you'll see that basically out of our
family group we're the second highest
um we're slightly lower than the
national average but actually
our economy is including that we are
seeing quite high levels of people on
benefits
in college comparatively
in
two this is working on looking at um
has become a direct housing supplier
excel consultant doing that he actually
has produced jeff reporting now so that
should be working through school council
soon
um
casual safeguarding policy has been
updated it's going to go to full council
in september
a couple of downsides here we're still
seeing high levels of people in
temporary accommodation returning to the
housing market and benefits and
everything and
we're seeing reductions a number of
people remember pops on a countertext
database
i think in june alone
it was minus 29 so
we are seeing people
moving out of the props and actually
letting them out as holiday let's as
businesses rather live living there so
um again that's not good for the housing
market locally
in benchmark in terms
i've actually pulled up the
house price change
uh the last 12 months up to may 21
so you'll see in terms of 15
year on year
um again second highest in our group
and
double the kind of average for england
so we're seeing very high house price
rises
and i saw some things recently for the
end of july year and year and it showed
the sixth highest council areas of the
country house price rises and west devon
north david told you in those six
so
he's getting higher and higher basically
so
what was a kind of uh
lower level is now going to get into
high level high property prices so again
it's putting pressure on
our housing stock
and affordable housing being available
thing three
local environments
um
carbon plant's been adopted
westerville beach got its blue flag 18
years in a row now which is very
impressive
our recycling levels are still remaining
high at 55.5 in the quarter one
we've seen a very high take of our
garden waste service
um
the price did cut by five pounds this
year and that's to look at the figures i
grew up with stickers down
at about 50 000 pounds more so
it's been successful so far
benchmarking now just picked on our
recycling level
um you'll see there we are
very much the top end of our family
group uh we used to be at the bottom end
and we're 10
higher than the english district
national average so
district council's average 10 higher and
we seem to be kind of just squeezing up
about each year we do a little bit more
so that's kind of still very positive
for the council actually cycling
and then theme four
big one there was elections taking place
um country elections on the police and
commissioner
there's lots of different proving
measures so that was quite a big success
for tom and his team
um
planning team in quarter one we're
having higher work volumes anywhere last
year so
um that hasn't let off at all that's
still
um
[Music]
so i've gotta work for the team
basically
and then russians are training now we're
trying to make the class website more
interactive and more modern and the
training is taking place the staff are
now working on the website pages
the negative picture was basically our
counter tax and business rates we're
still seeing
um
reduced levels of collection rates so
that's kind of a definite impact of
covid
and i just looked at benchmarking and
picked on our
cal state's collection rate last year
and you'll see we're in the bottom half
of the family group
um when i said like 50 percent we were a
half percent higher than the english
district average so
although it wasn't a great performance
we're still doing higher than most or
half of the other councils in the
country so
we are still kind of doing okay
and all councils obviously suffering and
have dropped off their collection rates
have any questions and i haven't have to
do it for the accounts
no questions
[Music]
the teams are currently leaving some
data across so we're hoping um in the
next few months we'll be able to have
something that we can share with members
we're not going to go live until
everybody's happy we want it to be
really right
for you know testing as well
so i kind of um
october november
with steam results in december
i'm sorry another question though
there's startling figures about some
universal credit take up house prices
etc all sort of combining
to
create possibly an emerging crisis of
people not having nowhere to live so i
mean are we looking at that in an
emergency sort of context
cheaper exactly answer that question um
yes thanks
for having me i was in an emergency
context
um we as you know we've had a couple of
workshops chris uh
earlier we've got a report coming back
to full council on those options for
members to consider but housing is not
and never
arrangements
really because universal credit is going
to be the increase is going to be taken
away in september
so you know what sort of strategy plans
have been put in place
but likely we don't have anything to do
with universities
talk about the effects
of the reduction of the 20 quid
a challenging one isn't it because
at the same time we know employers are
struggling to recruit so
there's a high
uptake of universal credit but there's
also a
high
proportion of vacant jobs in the market
so it's
how what's what's the link between those
why is this only jobs outstanding why is
it
such a highly level
universal credit
um
when is it being monitored in which or
which officers monitoring them
it's monitored and
we have regular reports on economic
factors and universal credit and
furlough
the county to a lot of
cross-country
data gathering and that gets fed into
um what's called that the herald group
which is the
um like a county-wide group looking at
economy where all the
um
kind of chambers
and all of those groups come together
to discuss the
what's happening in different sectors
to try and establish what the links are
between all these different factors
and obviously as county-wide
um recovery prospectus if you remember
that was approved by cnr
before last and that starting to build
on what impacts we can have if you
remember the last you know we sent
members outside money for
business support so
there are things being done but
um so there's
still a lot of issues
simon i'm just
looking ahead to where we're going and
i'm noticing in in the housing section i
mean
it'll take time for
the measures that
people alluding to to to actually show
on the ground so to speak but at the
moment there's no indication of that if
one looks number of approaches for
housing advice and number of homeless
applications are both down on this time
last year um now i'm not saying that
that won't change but it's it's the
it's the effect or the consequence that
we perhaps should be watching rather
than necessarily that people do adapt it
i mean we're not saying that people
won't adapt to a changing situation
um so
it's it's actually a number of number of
applications that start to come through
which will inform us better elect in
time
well the housing marketplace has changed
as chris mentioned earlier you know when
properties have come in vacant uh
they've been converted into
holiday let accommodation
we know properties are changing hands
for the cash cash buyers
and
going back to the the original question
steve that uh the the linkage between
the loss of of the
temporary universal credit um uh 20
pounds and and other factors
at the moment
are not
uh realizing themselves in more people
uh looking for for um
emergency housing or coming to us
looking good for housing at least not
yet not yet um
nick what what would you like to say
i'd like to say if you look at the
international scene over the last three
or four days we've seen
uh
situations being overtaken i just had to
watch the news last week and see what is
happening in cornwall
to realize that there's no use looking
because
today
or last week
you're going to see huge numbers of
people needing accommodation
and
temporary accommodation i mean we had
a talk about um almost containers that
have been watered
now we've got to be ready
we look at the parking lot
you could be right you could be right
nice anyway anybody else got any
questions
get on
oh sorry i'll share it thank you just to
add to that i mean i completely agree
and
there is a huge amount of anxiety out
there in the community about it
people are talking about it a lot and
there's there is a
um a lot of public feeling of france
that
things will need to change in the future
pretty quickly because there'll be a lot
of people in trouble
i'm sure monitor that gun um yesterday
anymore
there's housing points for something
that the council looked at
probably the year before 22 years ago
now
but at that time it wasn't something
that was progressed
in there partly to do with identifying
identifying sites for them to go on
because that's you know we want
something for them as well
and that's really something we certainly
gonna have to
revisit
yeah
okay
yes the report that's coming for council
does it look at the temporary emergency
situation is a more long term strategy
[Music]
term that that particular report is
looking into your long return housing
aspirations options so linked to the
workshop um
some member
remembers attended
last month
is there a gap on the short side then
at the moment
there isn't much that level of demand um
are we just gonna wait it sounds like we
need to
be prepared and it sounds like we're
just gonna wait so should we put
something forward today well i i don't
think it's a matter that we for me
anyway that
we're going to wait
is that i think we just need to look
into it to us to try to ascertain when
and and be ready for the win
you know but i don't think we're gonna
yeah
the problem with temporary accommodation
is the ability to move individuals on
because obviously as we know there's a
shortage of rent affordable rental
accommodation
so if you've got
and we have sufficient temporary
accommodation currently
if you get people into tech
accommodation you need to be moving the
market
is to move on that
is the particular problem we have at the
moment
as
to be aware of what interventions we
actually make at the moment
so a large part of our homelessness
is buying tennessee's balkans so what
they actually do for example is people
i've got enough money to
pay the
most rent in advance we're loaning that
one strength class if they haven't got
enough money to pay the damage deposit
to the landlord we'll loan that money to
our we'll pay to the landlord or we'll
have to guarantor the landlord in case
anything happens in tennessee so what
we're actually doing is quite heavily
investing
the council's money
okay
you may argue in the form of loans
very rarely get back to what they
there's a substantial right up i
probably say advance we get slightly
more than fifty percent of that but we
don't get all of it back obviously it's
obviously alone that are in a slightly
risky sector so to speak so it's quite a
large intervention that we do do already
maybe members aren't aware of that in
terms of how we back people who are
struggling to find attendance in the
commercial market with the council
coming on board behind them and saying
we will
act as guarantor any damage or we'll pay
the rent in advance that's required that
secures the tenancy so it's we're just
allowing people to access the privately
rented
property market with support from the
council activism guarantor
yeah but if there's a reduced reducing
amount of accommodation
as we should be identifying sites and
identifying some sort of temporary
units which we could
employ like foreign
we have privately at least accommodation
i think we have maybe four or five
it's not actually easy to find people
prepared to lease the property to us for
five years and then we'll place in and
we do go out quite often to solicit more
accommodation
um
sometimes we don't actually get
landlords wanting to lease the property
to us for five years or three years so
i'm saying that's one of the problems
our housing options by janet to come on
to your next meeting yeah to explain the
current situation
um explain perhaps a bit more detail
what uh david's referring to and try and
think of some of those options for the
virtual yeah you can do that you love
that thanks peter you made enough of
that john yeah
claire and then we're going to move on
additional property i'm going to mention
the fact
the work of people like citizens advice
in dealing with money management and
debt management
because this is critical for people who
may never have been in this position
before
to remain fully aware
of the services that are out there that
are available to the system
now i would like this counseling to
actively market
money advice and debt management advice
to people
who may be new customers
new clients of the advice agencies and i
think we need to be talking to citizens
advice and if you're going to have the
homeless team in it would be good to
hear from them as well the citizens
advice as to what they are encountering
and how best we can target
our limited resources into promoting the
work that goes on we're going to hear
about how the homeless team
are engaging with the private sector to
encourage
additional properties coming on board
we have also heard that houses are
disappearing off our books because
they're being let as holiday businesses
that may be a balloon that may burst
when the weather changes and people can
travel abroad so we might be
anticipating
a future where some of these landlords
are going to want to come back
to us so we need to have a really robust
incentivization to join our private
sector leasing to try and resolve this
problem we're not going to get much into
it into that until the turn of the year
are we
when when
at the minute we when everything
everything is gone
things have gone on everything
and you can't get anything but container
right when when people have had their
holiday and maybe then they started
looking and saying well we will be able
to go abroad
then don't dump us
yes and they were and then that's when
we looked at at the situation that we're
in at the end of the year forgive me
chair i think that's too late we need to
be preparing for this now
so that we are ready at the end of the
year and when this opportunity arises to
actually launch it immediately not start
you know
everyone's entitled to their opinions on
this admittedly but i think leaving it
until it actually happens
we need to be on the front foot here and
we need to be ready to seize those
opportunities i i didn't mean that it
would happen at the end of the year i
thought that's when
people would start to look up or or even
all of you all of you left people would
start to think well you know i'm not
going to be able to fill my property
you know because because people are now
able to go and go abroad
which i mean
you know it's fantastic that i mean yeah
government going would you make a while
the sunshine with with this time but but
because i i don't think it will be there
next year unless we have a bit more
covered and we get locked down through
the first time
that's a very good
suggestion actually i i agree with
council arts and that that actually
not not looking at throwing money
necessarily
randomly at the problem or whatever but
a deliberate exercise to bring together
and identify everything that that's
there to make sure that we actually
use it or clients use it to the maximum
because they are more aware that's
something quite different to what was
being discussed earlier and i i think
that's yeah i think that's very good
that i'm not sure we've done earlier
i would sooner say that this is for
example it's external probably but yeah
it crosses the boundary crosses about
right
can we make a recommendation to external
sorry can we make a recommendation to
external to oh you're on actually yes
i'm
[Music]
anyways
right feel the notice and make sure
you're coming on to
push it real quick
let's get on let's get on
right
where do we get to chris
david
well i'll just go through the finance
elements of the qbr one so in front of
us there we've got the income
and salaries at the bottom
um my color blindness won't help but
obviously everything that's in green is
actually better than the budget
uh remind me chris the things in what i
would call pink are they the ones that
are marginally below
yeah yeah
on that the pay and display the car
parking that's actually picked up since
then i mean we've actually had some
seriously record levels of income and in
july onwards so i'd actually parking
will come in above target i would
suspect but that will come into qpr so
yeah yes
um
so basically all the income's above
budget essentially if you look at some
of the notes obviously the comparison
with this time last year is a bit
nebulous um in many occasions because
obviously we were in full lockdown in
april may june of 2020 so we you know we
weren't getting any pain display income
and land charges was particularly light
etc
um on the salaries we've got vacancies
at the moment um excluding the refuge
and operations so where a refuge driver
vacancy occurs we'll just fill that
straight away with agency where they are
more office based
they can see occurs we'll go out to
recruitment won't necessarily place
immediately with age and set so that's
just to give some context
so
yeah so the the main thing that on this
slide is i'm forecasting an
understandable 685 000.
and there's two tables below which are
the overspend and the underspend which
explain how we've arrived at that point
as chris alluded to our playing
colleagues are particularly busy um
obviously i'm forecasting into the
future based on one or one quarter of
data
but i'm expecting the planning in
contact with 170 000 above budget which
is actually 64 of our budget i mean it's
on course to almost rival last year
where we were basically 500 000 pounds
budget
uh we've received some new burdens
funded for the administration of the
restarts grants and discretionary grants
of 228 000 that wasn't budgeted for we
didn't know that was coming
and we've got a receipt sales particular
sale of an easement in um i think it's
south street in torrance of 84 000.
um like i said car parking income
forecasting is going to be above target
um
as is building control
on the negative side
we
the estimate there of the administration
the discretionary grants that's from our
colleagues at north devon plus and it is
an estimate it will depend on the
volumes they receive and the amount of
hours that they allocate to it so i'm
probably being a little bit on the high
side there but uh i'd be cautious
we've had some expenditure within um
building control on dangerous structures
um
and there's nothing much else to report
on the sort of adverse side at this time
so what i'm saying at the moment i'm
forecasting 685 000 spent so caveat i
would give to that as we are still in a
degree of financial uncertainty
in terms of government support we're
constantly
being honest getting bits and pieces of
grant money from the government for for
example we're currently administering
track and trace self-isolation paper so
somebody's been told to isolate they're
not as fortunate as my good self who
would get sick pay for that time
they will get 500 pounds
basically which is to encourage them not
to go out to work essentially
and we get an admin grants for doing
that work and we've been doing probably
30
to 40 self-isolation payments every week
for probably now
two three months
so it depends how long that goes on so
that's just an example of additional
grant income that's coming through so
we've got about eight and a half
thousand pounds literally yesterday and
now so we're going to get happening that
i suspect there's other grants as well
coming through so
at the moment the 685 the caveat on that
is it's still a little bit uncertain
i mean to be honest this next slide i
won't um i'll flick through this one
very quickly because i've just talked
all about it on the previous slide i'm
really just giving you the reasons why
i'm forecasting and unspent
just to note um
the actual salaries we've incurred today
131 000 at the end of quarter one we
actually set a target for salary vacancy
savings of 300 000 so we always know
there's always going to be vacancies and
there's always going to be a delay from
somebody handing in their notice
finishing and the new person who
replaces them coming on stream you know
the interview process the application
process and the
um various reference checks et cetera so
we've made 131 000 at the end of the
first quarter our target is 300 000.
i've not made any assumption that we
will exceed that i assume we'll meet
that target
um so what we've got here is the capital
so
obviously we've got a quite a large
capital program for this year
and um we've been there i think some of
the narrative gives some more context to
it
um
so for example on the property and
infrastructure we've got a
capital budget there of 9.3 million
but obviously over 7 million of that
relates to the new environmental sensor
and it's probably unlikely that we'll
spend certainly a billion life we'll
spend the full seven million in this
year
we you know we're in advanced
discussions to secure a site but um
i'd be surprised if we spent all that
money in this financial year so i'm just
going to give on this one the context of
why
um
we've got such a large program spend is
relatively low because it's dependent on
some large projects
so the next slide is about the amount of
reserves so we actually see there
something that says total amount
reserves
15.5 million
and the financial year 2000 2021 was an
exceptionally unique for various reasons
and some context needs to be given
to those earmarked
reserves so
i've listed uh
the the various research there's a big
reserve um to deal with um business
rates
so we had to we had a deficit on our
business rates so at the start of the
year
we have a budget to collect business
rates of over 11 million pounds in
reality because of all the governments
and reliefs that were awarded and we
only actually collected four million
pounds so we have a big big deficit on
the business rates
however government gave us grants for it
but because of the unique feature of the
collection fund accounting we couldn't
realize that deficit
in
2020-21
we can only realize that this is
essentially what we do as we put the
government's grants aside which has
compensated us for the business rates we
haven't collected put that into reserve
and then we've got to pay back the
deficit in the current financial year
2020-21
which is a long-winded way of saying
don't think you've got and a half
million pounds of grants to spend is
what i'm trying to say
and then another factor there that
they're called with grants we've got
covered grants from central government
in advance of spending them
and simply we have to put that money
away into reserve because potentially we
could repay the grant back to government
or in reality the expenditure will be
incurred in 2021-22
so what i'm trying to do is give that
the the context there so if you ignore
the capital because we know the capital
programme is going to be under some
pressure because of construction price
inflation
we've got amount reserves of about 3.8
million and i've listed some of the main
ones and for example of course we
agreed to put 770 000 away into the
legend knowing the commitments are going
to come forward on leisure
um
again a very unique year
we've never had so much cash
and the reason we've had so much cash is
the government gave us money for various
restart grants
and wasn't very um
descriptive
in telling us when they actually would
want the money back
so we were just waiting for an email
from the government to say can you
please do recky up on your restart
grants and pay us back but we're we're
always waiting on government for that so
we've never had so much cash going
through the coffers of the council
um and hopefully members are pleased to
know we made our first um ethical
investment
on a lloyd's bank and and and also the
other thing was there was no cost to the
council of doing that it was the same as
if we just invested in a normal
short-term treasury deposit
um happy to take any questions you may
have
any questions today
are you looking to invest some more
yes basically the default soundcast
ranges we do that's the default when
they come up for anyone that is the
default that we will do
i think there's probably time cannot be
entirely sure when the treasury policy
was approved i think it would probably
be late september
february i started february i should say
and then it depends when they come up
for a renewal i mean at the moment there
is no difference on them
particularly when we do 90 days it's the
same for
the only problem we do our council aims
at the moment is because of the
uncertainty from the government when
they want back the ground money they've
given us it was not spent we're kind of
just on a holding pattern of very
short-term deposit because we don't want
to put away for a year and then
government comes back and says can we
have it back in six weeks so it's so
it's not the easiest treasury management
environment for us to be working in that
moment apart from that we're not worried
about cash flow
any other questions
council or laws
just like
narrative environmental
we've got the torrent and extension for
the cemetery
and then 157.000
[Music]
[Music]
um to my internal embarrassment given
i've written a slide no i don't actually
i'm being perfectly honest i could get
back to you and council
what are you doing
i i don't know
i've got to dig up the um capital pick
that'll have the detail
[Music]
let me dig out the original capital pit
and i'll come back
any more questions
all right okay
no that's fine man
thank you
apologies basically the basic
recommendation is is that given the
financial uncertainty in terms of one
future government funding in this year
and the autumn sector well they say
autumn settlements really win servant
management central government
that we defer any decisions to do the
projected surplus until later in the
year essentially so we won't make any
decision at this juncture we'll just um
defer until more information is now go
after the spending revenue but there's
been viewer plus also which probably
isn't articulated in there
how much additional government grants
money will come in during the course of
the year that we don't know at this
juncture
sorry simon that need a proposal
yeah we need to propose what we're
proposing is to receive well we receive
and note the qbr
that a decision on the um utilization of
the projected surplus is deferred until
after the spending review
that's what we're proposing um
proposal simon
uh stephen bengay second all those in
favor then
that's all of us yeah
okay
that's fine
thank you david
a wonderful job
enjoy everything getting around the
goldfish
right okay we're we'll move on there
item number nine graham brands
maintenance
sorry sorry i didn't did you want to go
through the
question
oh sorry yes yes
um getting ahead of myself
okay we've got uh questions and answers
um
okay everybody got a copy of it yeah
yeah
well
we'll start on page one
um
property questions from ian alpha how
many units are empty well we've got
a very long answer there
and everybody agree with that
everybody's happy with
that ian after you were happy with it
i'm happy with it just interested that
the holes were the three industrial
units that are um unreliable due to
insufficiency consumer ratings what's
happening we're doing something about it
or we're just letting it
to look at the units for potential
future development but given the quantum
of work the property team have already
it's kind of not the top of the list but
it is a piece of work they definitely
confidence estate manager we we
reduce rent for any attendance too well
everybody happy with that answer
and the next one
[Music]
we're going to page two
property questions from steve
banking
everybody read that answer from tom
phillips
estates manager everybody happy with
that
[Music]
just
steve just i'm sorry well just a
question that to know that on the impact
assessment of kobe has not been an
assessment done
and that i understand that but at some
point it might be that we
um
if you calculate from the income
monitoring section the difference is 148
you've answered that david yeah
okay everybody happy with that answer
phase three
attracting inward investment question
for me and alpha
page 16 on the qb
channel
yes yeah
the answer i i find somewhat um
the music
is this is the answer from sean k yes
are we getting false or wrong
information on the qbr
what is the information
it says the overall position statement
on the qbr is an accuracy
i think i might be able to help a little
bit generally
because
uh circulating um
on the business plan um when it was
agreed there was a target of 18
18 jobs
um to be kind of that that was one of
the measures um
chris has gone back to sean and um chris
fuller to say you know kind of where
does this figure come from and where are
you on it um and they're actually not
quite sure where the 18 came from so i
think they're kind of looking really
looking at it to make sure that
they've got more of an accurate figure
or um not putting something down that
they can't actually measure
so
we're still looking at kind of the
detail of that okay
yeah we can put it on that put that on
the action listen
yeah
right next one um
looking at the devon delivery's website
uh sean connie's answer there
everybody happy with that
ian
i know that shawn has said about uh
financial interest but what about other
industries in other words we've got
empty offices why can't we do something
like that at the end of the day
we're in a competitive market attracting
new businesses into this area and that's
one of the problems we have when we look
at all the recipes
at the end of the day we are right down
on ash that's the annual survey of the
earliest in the country
we've looked at the
universal credits so there's an issue
there unless we get the jobs up
we can't afford the rents from the rates
we live here
yeah so that's one of the issues i have
is that
where are we going with this yeah
there's a bit of a chicken in excavation
with this isn't it because we are also
particularly aware that some businesses
are not developing
because of house prices because knowing
that they can't attract
staff to resource the additional
business growth so it's a
bit of a circular problem
to be to be resolved so
it's it's something it's being discussed
in across the
kind of recovery coordination groups to
look at what options there are obviously
there's government funding all these
type of things we'll be looking at those
types of news as well so you feel like
leveling up all the leveling up agenda
so you know chris sean and the rest of
the team are looking at projects that
can attract
investment into the area with the hope
of attracting uh greater jobs you know
we acquired middle dock for that
that very further so there's projects
going on
it's a
difficult areas as we all know
it's my article okay
but the other thing is one of the things
i asked was that the sectors were
attracting
are we still because i looked at the
devil deliveries and northern devil was
looking very much at some
point the old traditional type uh
yet when you look at exeter they're
looking at something totally different
while we're being a little bit more
adventurous adventurous change
yeah i'll just go just come back so the
the
funded submissions from the the
biosphere in particular are looking at
uh much higher skilled type jobs
so that's a bid that's currently in with
the community renewal fund
and i think the government were due to
announce the results and those
applications in july that's been delayed
for whatever reason
um and
i think we like it here hopefully next
uh next month again they are
specifically looking at
higher level
types of industry sectors higher jobs
okay so we move on from page three now
then
then over to page four
the first first question from steve
dengan everybody's ready
everybody happy
stephen
yeah well just i mean the suggestion
once we considered whether that needs to
stay in or not
we've probably decided it has because
it's there but it sits at zero most of
the time
now just what i said was reviewing the
qpr at your next meeting i would suggest
these type of suggestions would go to
that if a committee then decide to take
it out they can take it out at that
point yeah we'll do it when we
review the qbl which next week yeah
okay thanks
down the page
[Music]
interesting point is the last sentence
in janet williams response
[Music]
everybody
anybody got any questions
[Music]
a great deal to update in terms of
specifics and the team are carrying on
uh working on the in-house transfer of
the service richard obviously looking at
the details specifications the the sites
and so forth
and our hr team dealing with the the
staff transfer
so it is progressing but that's
what i've updated this week okay
so
let's think about saving salaries i mean
we're going in house on ground
maintenance and
setting up um possibly on leisure i mean
are we happy that we you know the staff
are going to be there to deal with the
workload
on grounds maintenance we know currently
they
they're struggling to recruit we know
they're starting to recruit in the
leisure sector as well so
it's a problem in every sector i think
recruitment
i think uh tivoli are using agency staff
currently
yeah which is which is more expensive um
in terms of salary savings council games
not quite sure what you were
referring to
because i'll just remind you that the
discussions on malaysia we're in part
two of all councils yeah so we need to
be mindful of that we're not going to
discuss that here
i've just
emphasis on saving
salary
expenditure i mean are we happy
generally within
the council that we have the resources
staff resources to deal with
everyday business particularly on this
ground maintenance on us
that'll be part of the project plan as i
said richard is looking at the sites
he's looking at the staff resources
needed
to deliver that survey so if there's a
particular problem or risk that would be
brought forward
strategy update from attack and finish
group well
do you want to say anything john or do
you want me to just
i thought you were ready all right
well we we have started the task and
finished group which you all know um
we're at the moment with the tuscan
finish group we're looking through every
page of the strategy
i think we've probably covered three
quarters so far
uh our next meeting we'll be looking at
the rest of it and then we'll be
seeing if there's anything needs to
change we think
if anything needs changing
uh etc and so
by that time by the time we have
our next meeting we should have a much
better
update
with it all together
okay
consideration of the forward plan i film
11.
okay
well
for you september's september's meeting
is leisure contract update
capital paid process
uh qbr review
an stream review update from jack and
finish
yeah
is it looking at that is it too early to
do a qbr review after only having looked
at one iteration of the new qbr
should we not
be waiting until after qbr2
and then we re we review it i think just
well but
over this period of the year there's no
there's no reason why we can't review it
pretty regularly
to make sure that we are on the right
track and and
i think john's already mentioned we can
put something in or take something out
of the qbr if we look at it this time
yeah
and so yeah i don't know i i think it's
a good idea actually
i don't think we want to be tinkering
with it too much i mean
once once we've
landed on where we think it informs us
best
we
largely want to leave well alone if we
can if we can because we need that
continuity and familiarity so if we're
ever chipping and changing with it in
terms of don't want to be chocolate
changeable
um i would have personally i would have
liked one more iteration before we
[Music]
look we'll review our work and see
whether um
you what what you saying and we we
should leave it till we do tbr too
in november yeah yeah yeah okay anybody
agree we'll leave it to november
[Music]
we've got janet in there there's your
contract update which we should have a
little bit more
detail by the entrepreneur which i
presume you mean the the leisure service
rather than the contract yeah
the leicester service
we should have some we should have some
um
knowledge on the capital process by then
[Music]
it after this yeah but we will be
reporting
at that meeting and if if if the
recommendations of our report are
adopted yeah and accepted then
that will then
yeah
does it require will it require further
endorsement or just will it now
full council or or cnr or what whatever
what happens is that would be the
document used for this coming round of
um
background information to the project
it's only the approval of the actual
project which needs more council yeah so
what will happen is those documents will
be used for the workshop we promote
annually for members to look at the
capital projects
yeah so
all
which is why obviously david needs
that to be
signed off
because we need to get out of the things
in the diary we're not going to say
next we don't need anymore
[Music]
i've delegated
okay so
um
so we're happy with
with the 28th september yeah
and it what about the what about the
november i mean
december looked alright as well then we
ended into february budget special
[Music]
what is that john
it was um
inviting the leader and the uh chief
exec along oh yes that's right yeah dude
good question
to
answer the uh granted
during the covering yeah we're going to
have a big light up so they can sit i
was holding just christmas presents
yeah
that's
that's right well we need to we need to
do that sometimes
yeah but that you you and that you and
ken are there yeah
yeah you can understand the process that
sits behind
the need for those
particular decisions that's right
and it's a basic instrument of audience
as well yeah but actually you and i have
not been
not not not being unkind at all but it
is beneficial that you and the leader
get the opportunity to justify the
decisions you took
in
in an open council um
and then as well as always
for your own protection
there aren't that many and obviously
they get reported to community resources
straight after
any decisions taken anyway so it does go
through a
transparent process
okay
what's the process with the uh report on
affordable housing does that go to
council
[Music]
all right
that's it guys um thank you for coming
very meeting